So today I want him to
then, uh, the today,
the title of today's lecture is, um, uh,
uh, what is it, uh, the universal
principle of risk management,
a pooling and the hedging of risk.
Uh,
and what I'm really referring
to is I think the, the,
the very original,
the deep concept that
underlies theoretical finance.
I wanted to get that first.
Uh, and it really is
probability theory, uh,
and the idea of spreading
risk through risk pooling.
So this idea, uh, is, um,
it's an intellectual construct that, uh,
appeared at a certain point in history,
uh, and it has had
amazing, uh, number of, uh,
applications and finance is one of these.
Uh, so I, I want some of
you, uh, this incident,
they will be a more
technical of my lectures.
And so it's a little bit unfortunate
that it comes early in the semester.
For those of you who've had a course
in probability and statistics,
there will be nothing new here. Uh, well,
nothing in terms of the mat of the
probability theory, new, uh, others.
Though I want to tell you
that, uh, uh, it doesn't,
uh, if you're shopping, if I had a student
come by yesterday and ask that, uh,
he's a little rusty and his math
skills and should he take this course?
And I said, well, if you,
if you can understand, uh,
two miles elected as today's lecture,
uh, then you should have no problem.
Uh, but, uh, so I wanted
to start with the, uh,
the, uh, concept of, of
probability. And, uh,
you know what a probability
is. Uh, it's a no,
we attach a probability to an event.
Okay.
So what is the probability that the
stock market will go up this year? Okay.
Uh,
I would say point my
personal probability 0.45.
And so that's what I'm
a bear. But, uh, that's,
you know what that means that 45 times
out of a hundred of stock market will go
up and the other 55 times out of 100,
it will stay the same or go
down. Uh, that's a probability.
Uh, and now you're familiar
with that concept, right?
If someone says the probability is 0.5,
5.45,
you know what that means.
But I wanted to emphasize that it
always hasn't always been that way.
Uh,
and that probability is really a
concept that arose in the 16 hundreds,
uh,
before that nobody ever
said that Ian Hacking,
who is a,
uh,
he wrote a history of probability theory
searched through world literature for
any reference to a probability and
could find none anywhere before 1600.
So there was an intellectual leap
that occurred in the 17th century,
uh,
and it became a very fashionable
to talk in terms of probabilities.
It spread throughout the world, the
idea of quoting probabilities. Uh,
but it was, it's, it's, it's
funny that's such a simple idea.
Hadn't been used before.
Hacking points out that, uh,
the word probability or probable
was already in the English language.
Uh, in fact, Shakespeare used it.
But what do you think it meant
now? He gives an example of, um,
a young woman who was describing
a man that she likes and she says,
I liked him very much. I
find him very probable. Okay.
What do you think she means?
Cause I'm going to answer that.
Then he went no Elizabethan English well
enough to tell me what does a probably
young man anyway, I'm
asking for an answer.
Say it sounds like people have no idea.
Right.
Okay.
Anyone venture a guess?
Yeah,
no one wants to venture a guess
that he can father children.
Uh,
I don't think that's what she meant,
but maybe now what? Uh, what, uh,
apparently she met is trustworthy.
Okay.
That's very important quality
in a person I suppose. Right?
So if something is probable, you
mean that you can trust it. Okay.
And so probability means
trustworthiness. And so, uh,
uh,
you can see how they moved from that
definition of probability to the current
definition.
Um,
but Ian Hacking being a good
historian, uh, thought, you know,
someone must've had some concept
of probability going before, uh,
even if they didn't quote it as a number
the way there must have been in their
head or in their idea.
So he searched through world literature
to try to find some use of the term that
preceded the 16 hundreds.
And he concluded that there were probably
a number of people who had the idea,
but they didn't publish it. And it
never became part of the established,
uh, uh, uh, literature. Uh,
partly because he said
throughout human history,
there has been a love of gambling and
probability theory is extremely useful if
you are a gambler.
And hacking believes that there were
many gambling theorists who invented
probability theory at
various times in history, uh,
and never wrote it down. And
I kept it as a secret. Uh,
and he gives an example.
I like to, um, uh,
he gives an example from a book that,
or it's a collection.
No,
this, uh, I think there's a,
this is a collection of epic
poems written in Sanskrit.
Uh, and that goes back, uh,
it actually risen written over a
course of a thousand years, uh,
and it was completed in the fourth
century. Uh, well, there's a story,
there's a long story in the Mahabharata,
uh,
about a emperor called Nala.
Uh,
and he had a wife named Demante,
uh,
and he was very pure and
very good person. Uh, but,
uh, there was an, uh,
an evil demon called Kali who hated
Nava and wanted to bring his downfall.
So we had to find a weakness of Nala.
Uh,
and he found finally some, even though
Nala was so pure and so perfect,
he found one weakness and
that was gambling. Now,
I couldn't resist the
opportunity to gamble.
So the evil demon seduced
him into gambling aggressive.
And you know how sometime
when you're losing,
you readable and you keep hoping to
win back what you've lost? Uh, in a,
in a fit of gambling,
Nala finally gambled his
entire kingdom and lost,
okay. The terrible story and not a
of them had to leave the kingdom.
And his wife and, uh,
they wandered for years.
He separated from her
because of dire necessity.
They were wandering in the
forest, uh, and he was in despair,
having lost everything.
But then he meets, uh,
someone by the name of a,
who do we have here we have Nala,
and he meets this man to paranoia.
And this is where a probability
theory apparently comes in.
[inaudible] partner tells not lot that
he knows the science of gambling and he
will teach it to Nala,
but it has to be done by whispering in
his ear because it's a deep and extreme
secret.
And Nala is skeptical.
How does [inaudible] and know
how to gamble? Uh, and so, uh,
too paranoid tries to prove to
him his abilities. And he says,
see that tree there,
I can estimate how many leaves there are
on that tree by counting want leaves on
one branch.
So over to paranoia looked at one branch
and then estimated the of leaves on the
tree.
And Nala was a skeptical.
So he stayed up all night and counted
every leaf on the tree and it came very
close to what Nala or lot route
two parent. I said, uh, and so,
uh, he next morning believes Nala
and begins I believe for two partner.
Uh, now this is interesting.
Uh, hacking says,
because it shows that sampling theory, it
was part of knowledge theory. You could,
you don't have to count
all the leaves on the tree.
You take a sample and you count
that and then you multiply. Um,
so anyway,
they story ends.
Nala goes back and now armed
with probability theory,
we assume he goes back and Gamble's again.
He has nothing left to wager
except his wife. So he back,
he puts her and Gamble's her,
uh,
if I remember now he
knows what he's doing. Uh,
and so he really wasn't gambling his wife.
He's really a very pure
and honorable man. But, uh,
and so he won back the entire kingdom.
Uh, and uh, that's the ending.
So anyway, that shows that
I think probability theory
does have a long history,
but it not being an intellectual
discipline, it didn't really inform,
uh, uh, a generation of finance.
When you don't have a theory,
then you don't have a way
to be rigorous. So, um,
it was in the 16 hundreds that probability
theory started to get written down as
a theory and many things
then happen in that century,
which I think are precursors
both to finance and insurance.
One was in the 16 hundreds,
people started constructing life tables.
What does a life table?
It's a table showing the probability of
dying at each age for each age and sex.
Okay, that's what you need to know
if you're going to do life insurance.
So they started to do collecting of
data on mortality and they developed
something called actuarial science,
which is estimating the
probability of people, uh, living,
uh, and so, uh, uh, that, uh,
then became the basis for insurance.
Now actually insurance goes back
to ancient Rome in some form.
In ancient Rome, they had
something called burial insurance.
You could buy a policy that
protected you against your family,
not having the money to
bury you if you died, uh,
in an ancient culture of people worried
a great deal about being properly buried.
Uh, so that's an interesting concept. They
were selling that, uh, in ancient Rome.
But, uh, you might think, well,
why just for burial, why not?
Why don't you make it into
a full blown life insurance?
And you kind of wonder why they didn't.
Uh,
I think it's maybe because they
didn't have the concepts down. Uh,
in renaissance Italy,
they started writing insurance policies.
But I read one of the insurance policies.
It's in the Journal of risk and insurance.
They translate a renaissance
insurance policy. Uh,
and it's very hard to understand
what this policy was saying.
I guess they didn't have our language.
They didn't, uh, it was, uh, uh,
there were intuitively halfway there,
but they couldn't express it.
So I think the industry didn't
get really started. So, uh,
I think it's the invention of
probability theory that really starts,
and that's where I think theory is
very important in finance. And I,
um,
uh,
some people date a fire insurance
with the fire of London in 1666.
The whole city burned down,
uh,
practically in a terrible
fire and fire insurance.
I started to proliferate right after
that in London. But, uh, you know,
you kind of wonder if that's a good
example for fire insurance because if the
whole city burns down, insurance companies
would go bankrupt anyway. Right? Uh,
London insurance companies would,
because the whole concept of insurance
is pooling of independent probabilities.
Uh, and so, uh, but nonetheless,
that was the beginning.
Uh, we're also going to, uh,
recognize however that insurance
got a slow start because,
and I believe it is because people
could not understand the concept of
probability. They didn't have,
uh, they didn't have the, uh,
concept firmly in mind. There's
a lot of aspects to it. You know,
there's an APP in order
to understand probability,
you have to take things as
coming from a random event. Uh,
and people don't clearly have that in
their mind from an intuitive standpoint.
They have maybe a sense that I can
influence events by willing or wishing a,
and if I think that if I have
kind of a mystical side to me,
then probabilities don't
have a clear meaning. Uh,
and it's been shown that even today,
people seem to think that,
that they don't really take at
an intuitive level probabilities,
uh, uh, very, uh, as objective.
So for example,
if you ask people how much they would
be willing to bet on a coin toss,
they were,
they will typically bet more if they can
toss the coin or they will bet more if
the coin hasn't been tossed yet and
it could have been already tossed in
concealed. And what, why would that be?
It might be this just some
intuitive sense that, um,
that I, that I can, I dunno, I can,
I have some magical forces in
me and I can change things.
So the idea of probability
theory is that no,
you can't change things.
There are these objective
laws of probability out
there that guide everything.
Most languages around the
world have, uh, a different,
uh, uh, uh,
word for luck and risk or luck.
And a fortune luck seems to
mean something about you.
I'm a lucky person.
I don't know what that means.
Like the God or gods favor me.
And so I'm lucky.
This is my lucky day.
A probability theory is really
a movement away from that.
And so we then have a
mathematical rigorous, uh, um, uh,
discipline. So, uh, now I'm going
to go through some of the, um,
uh, some of the terms of
probability here and uh,
um, this will be review
for many of you, but, uh,
it'll be something that we're
going to use in the, um,
so I use
the symbol p or I can sometimes write it
out as probability to represent a prob
probability.
Okay.
And it is always a number of that lies
between zero and one or between 0% and
100%.
Okay?
Percent means divided by a hundred
in Latin, right? So 100% is one.
Okay. And so this is the probability.
If the probability is zero,
that means the event can't happen.
If the probability is one,
it means it's certain to happen.
If the probability is,
does everyone see this from over there?
And if I could move,
I can't probably move
this or can I? Yes, I can.
Can you, you're the most disadvantaged
person and you can see it, right?
Uh, so, uh,
uh,
that's the basic idea.
Uh,
now one of the first principles of
probability is the idea of independence.
Okay?
Uh,
so the idea is that
probability, uh, is the, um,
uh,
measures the likelihood of some outcome.
Let's say the outcome of an
experiment, okay? Like tossing a coin,
you might say the probability that you'd
toss a coin that it comes up heads is a
half. Okay. Because equally
likely it heads and tails, uh,
independent experiments are experiments
that occur without relation to each
other.
So if you toss a coin twice and the
first experiment doesn't influence the
second we say they're independent.
And so there there's no relation
between the two and one of the first of
probability that theory is
called the multiplication
rule.
And that says if you have
independent probabilities,
the probability of two events is equal
to the product and their probabilities.
So the probability of a and the
is equal to the probability of
a times the probability of B.
Okay.
Uh,
that wouldn't hold if
they're not independent.
The theory of insurance is that ideally
an insurance company wants to insure
independent events.
Okay.
And so ideally life
insurance is insuring people,
or fire insurance is insuring
people against independent event.
So it's not the fire of London,
it's the,
it's the problem that sometimes people
knock over an oil lamp in their home and
they burn their own house down.
Uh,
and so it's not going to
burn any other houses down.
It's this just completely
independent of anything else.
So the probability that the whole city
burns down is infinitesimally small.
Right. Uh, this, this will
generalize to probability of a,
and B and c is the probability of a times
the probability of B and probability
times the probability of c and so on.
So if their probability is
one in a thousand that a
house burns down and there's
a thousand houses,
the probability that they all burned
down is prob is one 1000th to the
thousandth power,
which is virtually zero.
And so insurance companies then basically
if they write a lot of policies,
they have virtually no risk.
Uh, and so that is the, um,
the fundamental idea,
which may seem simple and obvious to you,
but it certainly wasn't back
when the idea first came up. Uh,
so, uh, one of the, uh,
incident, we have a problem set,
which I want you to start
today and it will be do, uh,
not in a week this time because we have a,
uh,
Martin Luther King Day coming up,
but it will be due
the Monday following that. Uh, so the,
um,
uh,
if you follow through from the
independent theory, there's a, uh,
one of the basic relations in
probability theory is called the binomial
distribution.
And I'm not going to spend,
spend a whole lot of time on this.
Yes,
but it gives a probability of x
successes in n trials or in the case of
insurance, uh, x if you're
insuring against an accident,
the probability that you'll get
x accidents and, and trials.
So, uh, it,
the binomial distribution gives
the probability as a function of x,
and it's given by the formula where
p is the probability of the accident,
uh,
p to the x times one
minus P to the n minus x,
uh,
times n factorial over
and minus x factorial.
Uh, and so, uh,
that is the formula that insurance
companies use when they have independent
probabilities to estimate the likelihood
of a having a certain number of
accidents. They're concerned with having
too many accidents, which might, um,
exhausted their reserves to an
insurance company has reserves and they,
they,
they have enough reserves to cover them
for a certain number of accidents and
they use the binomial distribution,
uh,
to calculate the probability of getting
any specific number of accidents.
So, uh, that is the multiplication,
the binomial distribution.
So I'm
not going to expand the hunters
because I can't get into detail.
This is not of course in
probability theory, but, uh,
I'm hopeful that you can see the formula
and you could apply it. All right.
Any questions? Is this clear enough
and you read my handwriting? Um,
okay. So, um,
another important concept in probability
theory that we will use a lot is
expected value. Uh, and so, um,
the mean or average,
uh,
those are all roughly
interchangeable concepts.
So we have expected value
mean or average.
Okay. Um, so, uh,
but we can define it in a couple of
different ways depending on whether we're
talking about sample mean
or a population mean,
the basic definition,
the expected value of some
random variable x. Um,
I guess I should've said
he ran a variable is a, uh,
a quantity that takes on value is x.
If you have an experiment.
And the outcome of the experiment is a
number than a random variable is that
number which comes from the experiment.
So for example,
the experiment could be tossing a coin
and I will call the outcome heads the
number one and I'll call the
outcome tails the number zero.
So I've just defined a random variable.
You have discrete random variables like
the one I justified or there are also
con which take on only a
finite number of values.
And we have continuous random variables
they can take on any number of values
along a continuum.
Another experiment would be to say
mixed two chemicals together and put a
thermometer in and
measure the temperature.
That's another invention of
the 16 hundreds of by the
way, the thermometer. Uh,
and they learned that concept in the sig,
perfectly natural to us temperature,
right? But it was a new idea
in the 16 hundreds. So anyway,
that's continuous, right? When you
mix two chemicals together, uh,
it could be any number is an infinite
number of possible numbers and that would
be continuous for
discrete random variables.
We can define the expected
value or Musa backs.
That's the Greek letter mu,
uh, is the summation, uh,
I equals one to infinity
of the probability that x
equals x survive times x
rabbi. All right. So, uh, I,
I have it down that there might be an
infinite number of possible values for the
random variable x. In the case of
the coin toss, there were only two,
but I'm saying in general there
could be an infinite number,
but they're accountable.
And so we can list all possible values
when they're discreet and form a
probability weighted
average of the outcomes.
And that's called the expected value.
Uh,
and it's people also call that the
mean or the average, uh, often,
uh,
but you know that this is based on theory.
These are probabilities a,
okay.
In order to compute using this formula,
you have to know the
true pop probabilities.
There's another formula which applies
for a continuous random variables.
And it's the same idea
except that I'll also,
I'll call it muse of x,
except that it's an indoor.
So we have the inner girl
from minus infinity to plus
infinity of f of x times x
Dx. Okay. And that's really easy.
It's the same thing because in integral
isn't an analogous to a summation.
Uh,
those are the two population definitions.
F of x is a,
is the continuous probability
distribution for x.
Uh, it gives a, I will, uh,
well, yeah, so that's different.
When you have continuous values,
you,
you don't have the probability that x
equals x to buy because it's always zero.
The probability that the temperature
is exactly a hundred degrees is zero
because it could be a hundred 0.0, zero,
zero one degrees or something else.
And there's an infinite
number of possibilities.
So we have instead what's called the
probability density in when we have
continuous random variables.
Uh,
you're not going to need to know a lot
about this for this course, but this is,
I wanted to get the Jason,
the basic ideas down.
So these are called population measures
because they refer to the whole
population of possible outcome and
they measure the probabilities.
So it's, it's the truth, but
there are also sample means,
uh, when you would get,
this is, uh, the two parent.
Now counting the leaves on a tree,
you can estimate from a sample, uh,
the population expected values.
And so the population mean
is often written x bar.
If you have a sample with an observations,
it's the summation.
I equals one to n,
x of by divided by N. All
right? That's the average.
You know that formula, right? You
add, you get, you can't end leaves on,
you count the number of leaves. Uh, uh,
you have an well, you have
an branches on the tree, uh,
you count the number of leaves
and sum them up. Uh, one would be,
there is a, I guess I'm having a little
trouble putting this into the, uh,
the two part in the story, but you
see the idea, you know, the average,
I assume that's the most
elementary concept. Um, and,
uh,
and so you could use this to estimate
either a discrete or continuous expected
value. Uh, now they're in finance.
There's a often reference
to another kind of average,
which I want to refer you to and
which in the Jeremy Siegel book, uh,
there's a lot is made of this.
Uh,
and the other kind of average is
called the geometric average. Uh,
and so, um, we'll call that a,
I'm the only show the
sample version of it, uh,
g of x equals there's left
parentheses the product
I equals one to n act.
So by there's a one over
n power is everyone.
Can you see that back there?
Um,
maybe you have trouble seeing
that, but uh, it's different.
Instead of summing them
and dividing by him,
I multiply them all together
and the route of them.
Uh, so this is called the geometric
average and it's used, uh,
only for positive numbers. So if
you have any negative numbers, uh,
you'd have a problem, right? If
you had one negative number in it,
then the product would be a negative
number. And if you took a route of that,
you might get a, an agile, very number.
So we don't want to use
it in that case. But, uh,
uh,
there's a appendix two,
one of the chapters in Jeremy Siegel's
book where he says that one of the most
important applications of this theory is
to measure how successful and investor
is. Okay. So, um, uh, if,
uh, suppose someone is managing money, uh,
uh, have they done well?
If, so, you would say, well,
they've been investing money
over a number of different years.
Let's take the average over
all the different years. Okay.
So suppose someone has been investing
money for n years and rabbi is the return
on the investment in a given year.
What is their average performance was
the natural thing to do would be to
average them up. Right. Uh, now, uh,
but, uh, Jeremy says that maybe
that's not a very good thing to do.
Uh, so, um,
but he says you should do instead is
take the geometric average of gross
returns.
Okay.
That now what is the return on an
investment is how much you made from the
investment as a percent of
the money invested. Okay?
The gross return is the return plus one.
All right?
The worst you can ever do investing is
to lose all of your investment Lewis,
100%.
So if we add one to the return,
you've got a number that's never negative
and we can then use geometric returns.
Okay. Um, and so, uh, Jeremy Siegel says,
really in finance we should be
using geometric and arithmetic.
And why is that? Well, I'll
tell you in very simple term,
I think suppose someone is investing your
money and he announces I have had very
good returns.
I have invested and I've produced 20%
of the year for nine out of the last 10
years. And so you think, gee, that's
great. Well, what about the last year?
And the guy said, oh, I lost
100% in that year. Okay. Uh,
so you might say, all
right, that's good. So I,
I would add up 20% a year
for nine years and then,
uh, put in a zero, no, 120,
because it's grocery turned for nine
years and put in a zero for one year.
And then maybe that doesn't look
bad. Right? But think about it.
If you are investing your
money with someone like that,
what did you end up with?
You ended up with nothing. If they have
one year, when they lose everything,
it doesn't matter how much they
made in the other years. Uh,
so Jeremy says in the,
in the text is that the geometric return
is always lower than the arithmetic
return, unless all the numbers are
the same. Uh, and so it's a less,
uh, it's a less optimistic
version. And so we should use that.
But people in finance resist
using that, uh, because, uh,
it's a lower number and when
you're advertising your return,
you want to make it look as big
as possible. Okay. We also need,
uh, some measure. Uh,
we've been talking here about
measures of central tendency only, uh,
and in finance we need as
well measures of dispersion.
Uh,
that's how much something varies.
Central tendency is a
manager of the center of a
probability distribution of the
light.
But a central tendency is a measure of
variance is a measure of how much things
change from one observation to another.
So we have
variance,
uh, and it's measured often
represented by sigma squared.
That's the Greek letter
sigma, uh, lower case squared,
or especially when talking about, uh, um,
uh, estimates of the variance.
We sometimes say s squared,
uh, or, or we say standard deviation
squared.
Uh, the variance, the standard deviation
is the square root of the variance. Okay.
Uh, so for, uh, population variance,
the variance of some random variable x,
okay.
A is defined as uh,
the summation,
I equals one to infinity
of the probability that x
equals x by times x minus
new squared.
All right? So, um, new subjects,
new subjects is the mean.
We just defined it of x.
That's the expectation of acts
are also EMX. So it's the,
it's the probability weighted average
of the square deviations from the mean.
If it moves a lot,
either way from the mean,
then this number squared is a big
number. So the more x moves, uh,
the bigger the variances.
Okay. There's also another,
uh, variance measure a
which we use in the sample
also there. Sometimes he was, um,
so this is sigma squared.
There's also another variance measure,
which is where the sample and
when we have an observations,
it's this, uh, the summation,
I equals one to n of x minus
x Bar squared all over n Oh,
this should be squared.
Um,
okay,
so that is the sample variance.
Now some people will
divide by n minus one. Uh,
all right.
I suppose I would accept either answered,
I'm just keeping it simple
here. Uh, that's, uh,
they, they've divided by n minus one
to make it an unbiased estimator of the
population variance. But I'm just
going to show it in a simple way here.
So you see what it is. It's a measure
of how much x deviates from the mean,
but it is,
since it's squared,
it weights big deviations a lot because
the square of a big number is really big.
And so, um, that's the variance.
All Right, so that completes of
central tendency and dispersion.
Uh, we're going to be talking about these
in finance as regards returns because
generally the idea here is
that we want high return.
So we want a high
expected value of returns,
but we don't like variance.
So expected value is good,
variance is bad because that's
risk. That's uncertainty. West part.
This whole theory is about how to avoid,
how to get a lot of expected return
with, uh, without getting a lot of risk.
Now another concept that's
very basic here is covariance.
Covariance is a measure of how
much two variables move together.
Okay? So, uh, so covariants, uh,
is a
covariance.
Uh, we'll call it. Now we
have two random variables.
So the covariance of x and Y,
uh,
I'll just talk about it in a sample
term. Uh, it's the summation.
I equals one to n of x minus x Bar
Times y minus y bar all over N.
Okay. So, uh, ex, uh,
this is the deviation of,
or for the,
I thought I subscript,
meaning we have a separate eye,
uh, exit rabbi. And why?
So by for each observation,
so we're talking about an experiment.
When you generate,
each experiment generates
both an x and a y observation.
And we want to know
whether when x is high,
why also tends to be high or whether
it's the other way around. If,
if they tend to move together,
if when x is high and why is
high together at the same time,
then uh, the covariance will
tend to be a positive number.
Or also if x tens when x is low,
why also tends to be low,
then this will be a negative
number. And so, well this,
so their product is positive.
All right?
So a positive covariance means that the
to move together and negative covariance
means that they tend to move opposite
each other. So if x is high relative to x,
buy, this is positive then why it
tends to be low relative to its mean.
And this is negative.
So the product would be negative.
And if you get a lot of negative products
that makes the covariance negative.
Okay. Uh, and then I want
to move to correlation.
Okay.
So this is a measure, a,
it's a scaled covariance.
Uh, the correlation, how are we tend
to use the Greek letter role? Um,
or if you, um, where do you use excel?
It would be Corel or sometimes I say car.
Uh,
that's the correlation. Okay. Uh,
this number always lies between zero,
between minus one and plus one.
Uh, and what it is, uh,
is defined as Raul is equal
to the covariance of x and
y divided by the standard
deviation of x times the
standard deviation of y.
Okay. Uh, and uh, that's
the correlation coefficient.
So,
uh,
that has kind of almost entered the
English language in the sense that you'll
see it quoted occasionally in this papers.
So I dunno how used to it,
you know, uh, where would
you see that, you know,
they would say there is a low correlation
between sat scores and grade point
averages in, in college or maybe it's a
high correlation. I know what it, does.
Anyone know what it is? But you can
estimate a car. It's probably positive.
I bet it's way below one. Right.
But it has some correlation.
So maybe it's 0.3. Okay.
That would mean that, uh,
people who have high sat scores
tend to get higher grades. Uh,
if it were neg, it's very unlikely
that it's negative, right?
It couldn't be negative,
it couldn't be a,
that people who have high sat
scores tend to do poorly in college.
So if you want to quantify how
much they, uh, then you have to,
you can look at the correlation. Um, okay.
So, um, I want to
move to regression.
And this is another concept that
is very basic to statistics,
but yet,
um,
has particular use in finance.
Uh,
so I'll give you a financial example.
Okay.
So the concept of regression,
uh,
it goes back to the math and
efficient and Gauss, uh, who,
uh, talked about fitting a line
through a scatter of points.
So let's draw a, I took my watch
off and see my time here. Uh,
let's draw a line through a
scatter of points here. So this is,
uh,
I want to put down on this axis,
the return and the stock market.
And on this access,
I want to put the return on one company.
Let's say Microsoft,
okay.
And I'm going to have each
observation as a year. Okay.
I shouldn't put down a name of a company
cause I can't reproduce this diagram
for Microsoft. Uh, let's not
say Microsoft. Let's say,
uh, uh, Shiller Inc.
There is no such company. So I can
be completely hypothetical. Uh, and,
uh, this put zero here because, um,
and these are not grocery returns. These
are returns. So there are often negative,
okay.
And suppose that in a given year and
say this is minus five and this is plus
five is minus five plus five.
Suppose that, uh, in, in the
first year in our sample, uh,
the company Shiller Inc and the market
both did 5%. So that puts a pie,
a point right there, okay. At, uh,
at five and five. Okay. Uh,
and another year, however, uh, the,
the stock market lost 5%
and a Shiller ink lost 7%.
So we'd have a point say down here,
right at five and seven.
All right?
So this could be a 1979.
This is going to be 1980. Uh,
and we keep adding points. Uh,
so we've got a whole scatter of points.
All right.
It's probably upward sloping,
right?
Probably when the overall stock market
does well. So does a Shiller Inc.
All right,
so what gas dad is said,
let's fill aligned through the point,
uh,
this have points and that's
called the regression line.
And he chose the line so
that, uh, this is gauss.
Uh,
he said he chose the line to minimize the
sum of squared distances of the points
from the line. So these distances are
the lengths of these lines segments.
To get the best fitting line,
you find the line that minimizes
the sum of square distances,
and that's called the regression line.
And the intercept is called Alpha.
There is Alpha and the
slope is called Beta.
Okay? So that's maybe a
familiar enough concept to you.
But in the context of
finance, this is, uh,
this is a, uh, a major concept.
The way I've written it, uh,
the Beta of Schiller Corporation
is the slope of this line.
Okay? The alpha is, uh,
uh, is, is just the intercept
of this, of this curb. Um,
so, uh, we can also do
this with excess returns.
I will get to this later where I have the
return minus the interest rate on this
axis and the return minus
the market return minus the
interest rate on this axis.
And then that case Alpha is a
measure of how much Shiller Inc,
uh, outperformed, uh,
we'll come back to this,
but Beta of a stock is a measure of
how much it moves with the market, uh,
and the alpha of a stock is how much it's
sort of outperforms the market. Well,
we'll have to come back to that.
These are basic concepts. Um,
okay. So, uh, I wanted
to, oh, and another,
uh, so I guess I've been
implicit in what I have is there,
there's a distribution called
the normal distribution. Uh,
and that is, uh, uh, I'm
sure you heard of this,
right?
Uh,
if you have a distribution
that looks like this,
it's bell-shaped,
right?
This is x and I have to
make it look symmetric,
which I may not be able to do that well.
Okay.
And this is after the,
the normal distribution
is equal to the one over square root of
two Pi Sigma e to the minus x bar minus
mew squared over two sigma.
It's a famous formula which
is new gauss. Again, uh,
we often assume in finance that random
variables such as returns are normally
distributed.
So this is called the normal distribution
or the Gaussian distribution.
It's a continuous distribution. I
think you've heard of this, right?
This is a high school material.
Uh,
but I wanted to emphasize that there
are also other bell shaped curve.
This is the most famous bell shaped curve,
but there are other ones with different
mathematics and a particular interest in
finance are fat tailed alternatives.
So it could be that a random distribution.
And I'll,
I don't have colored chalk
here, I don't think. No.
So I will use a dash line to represent
the fat tail distribution because the
distribution looks like this.
Okay.
And then I have to try to do that on
the other side symmetrically as I can.
Okay.
These are the tails of the distribution.
This is the right tail
and this is the left tail.
Okay?
And you can see that the dash distribution
I drew has more out in the tails.
Okay? So we call it fat tailed. Uh,
this refers to a random variables that
have fat tail distributions are random
variables that occasionally
give you really big outcomes.
So you have a chance of being way out
here with a fat tail distribution.
And it's a very important observation
in finance that returns on a lot of
speculative assets,
have fat tail distributions.
That means that you can go through 20
years of a career on Wall Street and all
you've observed his observations in the
central region. And so you feel, you know,
a pretty well how things behave.
But then all of a sudden there's something
way out here. This would be great.
Good luck if you're long and now suddenly
you've just got a huge return that you
just would not have thought was possible.
You've never seen it before,
but you can also have an
incredibly bad return.
And this complicates finance because
it means that you never know.
You never have enough experience to,
um,
to get through all of these things.
Um,
it's a, it's a big complication in, uh,
my friend Nassim Taleb has just
written a book about it called,
maybe I'll talk about that
called the Black Swan. Uh,
and it's about how every,
so many plans in finance are messed up by,
um,
by a rare events that suddenly appear
that out of nowhere he called it the Black
Swan. Because if you look at
swans, they're always white, right?
You've never seen a black swan.
And so you end up going through life
assuming that there are no black swans,
but in fact, there are a, and
you might finally see one.
You don't want to predicate
making complicated gambles
under the assumption that
they don't exist. Um, and, uh,
so Tyler who's a Wall Street
professional, talks about, uh,
these black swans as being
the real story of finance.
Uh, I wanted to move away from
statistics and talk about present values,
does another concept in finance that is,
uh,
uh, fundamental. Uh, and so let me, uh,
and then this will
conclude today's lecture.
What is a present value?
This isn't really a statistics anymore,
but it's a concept that I wanted
to include in this lecture. Um,
people in business often
have claims on future money,
not money today. Uh, and um, for example,
I may have someone who promises to pay
me $1 in one year or in two years or
three years.
Okay.
The present value is what
that's worth today. Okay.
So I may have a,
a,
an IOU from someone or I may own a bond
from someone that promises to pay me
something in a year or two years.
Uh,
according to Time, honored
tradition in finance. Uh,
if it says that it's a promise to pay $1,
it's not worth $1 today. Uh,
it must be worth less than $1.
Uh,
so what you could do hundreds of years
ago and can still do today is to go to a
bank and present this, um, uh,
bond or Iou and say,
um,
what will you give me
for it? Okay. And so, uh,
the, uh, the bank, well discounted.
Oh,
sometimes we say present discounted value.
Yes.
So the banker will say, well,
you have $1 a year from now,
but that's a year from now, so
I won't give you $1 now. Uh,
I'll give you the present
discounted value for it. Okay? Uh,
now I'm going to abstract from risk.
Let's assume that we know that
this thing is going to be paid.
So it's a matter of simple
time, all right? Of course,
the banker isn't going to give you $1
for something that is paying $1 in a year
because the banker knows that a dollar
could be invested at the interest rate.
And so let's say the interest rate is r.
Okay.
Uh, and um, that, uh, uh,
that would be a number, um, which, uh,
like 0.05, which is 5%, which
is five divided by a hundred.
Uh,
then the present value of $1,
the present PDV or Pv have $1
equals one over one plus r dollars.
Okay? That's because the
banker is thinking, well,
uh, if, uh,
if I have this amount right now
and I invest it for one year,
what do I have? I Have One plus r times
one over one plus R it's a dollar.
So that works out exactly right.
So you have to discount something.
That's one period in the future
by dividing it by one plus R.
Uh,
if it's,
this is a present value
of $1 in one time period,
which I'm taking to be a year,
but it doesn't have to be a year.
The interest rate has units of time.
So I have to specify a time period over
which I'm measuring an interest rate.
So typically it's a year.
So if it's a one year interest rate
at the time period is one year,
the present value of $1 in one
time period is given by this,
the present value of $1 in end periods.
Yeah.
Is One Oliver,
one plus r to the nth power.
Uh, and uh, uh,
that is uh,
uh,
that's the, uh, all all
there is to this. Then, uh,
so,
uh,
I want to talk about
valuing streams of payments.
I suppose someone has a contract that
promises to pay an amount each period over
a number of years.
We have formulas for these peasant values,
uh,
and these formulas,
are well known. I'm just going to go
through them rather quickly here. Uh,
simplest thing is
something called a console
or perpetuity.
Okay.
I perpetuity is,
is a asset or a contract that pays a
fixed amount of money each time period
forever.
We call them councils because
in the early 17 hundreds,
the British government issued what they
called console's are consolidated a debt
of the British crown,
uh,
that paid a certain amount
of pound sterling every,
I think it was every six months forever.
Uh,
and you may say what audacity for the
British government did promise to pay
anything forever. Will it be
around forever? Well, you know,
as far as you're concerned, it's
as good enough as forever, right?
Maybe someday the British,
uh, uh, United Kingdom will,
something will happen to it.
It will fall apart or change.
But that is so distant in the future,
we can disregard that.
So we'll take that as forever in any way.
The government might buy them back too.
And so, you know, who cares
if it isn't for everyone.
Let's just talk about it as forever.
So let's say this thing pays
one pound a period forever.
Okay? Uh, what is the
present value of that?
Well, the first, uh, each payment
we'll call a coupon. Okay?
Okay.
So it pays one pound one year from now.
Let's say it's one year, just to
simplify things. It pays another pound.
Two years from now, it pays another
pound. Three years from now,
the present value is equal to remember
it starts one year from now under
assumption. We could, we
could do it differently,
but I'm assuming one year from now,
the present value is one over one plus
R it's one pound over one plus r for the
first year, right? Uh, plus, uh,
for the second year it's one
town over one plus r squared.
For the third year it's one pound
all over r one plus r cubed.
And that goes on forever.
So that's an infinite series
and you know how to sum that,
I think anyway,
I'll tell you what it is.
It's one over r or the one
pound over are generally,
if it pays see dollars for every period,
the present value is c over r.
And so that's the formula for
the present value of a console.
All right? That's one of the most
basic formulas in finance. Uh,
so,
uh,
the interesting thing is it means that
the value of a console moves inversely to
the interest rate.
The British government
issued those consoles in the
early 17 hundreds and while
they were refinanced in the late
19th century, they're still there.
And if you want to go out and buy one,
you can get on your laptop right after
this lecture and buy one of them and
you've got something that will
pay you something forever. Uh,
but you're going to know that the value
of that in the market moves opposite
interest rates. So if interest
rates go down, the value goes up.
If interest rates go up, the value
of your investment goes down. Okay?
Uh, another formula, uh,
is what if the console,
um, doesn't pay? Well, what I sorry.
Uh, next thing. It is a growing console.
Yeah.
I'm calling it a growing console, even
though the British console's didn't grow.
Let's say that the British government
didn't say that they'll pay one pound per
year, but it'll be one
pound the first year. Um,
and then, uh, uh, it'll
grow at the rate g,
uh,
and will eventually be infinitely large.
All right. Uh, so you get
one pound for the first year,
you get, uh, uh,
uh,
a one plus g pounds.
The second year it stopped Ya,
one plus g squared the third year.
And so on the present value of this,
I suppose it pays,
let's say it's PC pounds each year,
so it would be c times this.
All right,
one plus it would be c times one plus
g cubed and the third year, et Cetera.
Then the present value is
equal to c all over r minus G.
That's the formula for the
value of it growing. Cancel.
Um,
GE has to be less than our for this to
make sense because if g if it's growing
faster than the rate of interest,
this infinite series will not converge
and the value will be infinite.
Uh, and you might ask, well, how
does that make sense? What if,
what if the British government
promised to pay 10% more each year?
Uh, what would the market value that
with formula doesn't have a number?
Well, I'll tell you why.
It doesn't have a number.
The British government will never promise
to pay you 10% more each year because
they can't do it and the market wouldn't
believe them because you can't grow
every year faster than the interest rate.
And that's a basic one of the most
basic lessons. You can't do it.
Um, okay. Uh, one more thing. I think it,
which would be relevant to the, uh,
oh, there's also the annuity formula.
And this is a formula that applies to,
um,
what if an asset pays a fixed
amount every period and then stops.
That's called an annuity. Okay. So, uh,
an annuity
it pays. See, I'll go back to dollars.
See dollars starting in, uh, t equals one,
two, three, and is the last period.
And that stops.
A good example of an annuity
is a mortgage on a house.
Uh, you, when you buy a house,
you borrow the money and you pay it back
in fixed, it would usually be monthly,
but let's say annual payments.
All right?
You pay every year a fixed them out on
your house to the mortgage originator.
Uh, and then after so many n
is 30 years, typically you,
uh,
you would then have a paid off.
It used to be that mortgages had a blue
called a balloon payment at the end,
which means that you'd have
to pay extra money at the end,
but they decided that people
have trouble doing that.
It's much better to pay a fixed payment
and then you're done. Otherwise,
if you ask them to pay more at the end,
a lot of people,
they won't have the money.
So we now have a nuity mortgages.
What is the present value of an annuity?
Okay.
And so that is the
present value of annuity.
It is equal to the amount,
what did I say is c times
one minus one over one plus r
to the nth power,
all of our r.
And so that is the present
value of an annuity.
Um,
I wanted to say one more thing because
I realized that you have to your,
your first problem set,
we'll cover this,
is to talk about a concept that applies
probability theory to economics and that
is expected utility theory.
Uh,
and then I'll conclude with this. Uh, the,
in economics,
it is assumed that people have a utility
function which represents how happy
they are, uh, within outcome.
Okay. And so we typically
take that as you, uh,
and uh, uh, so if I
have a monetary outcome,
I have a certain amount of money,
x dollars,
how happy I am with x dollars is called,
you have x. Okay. Uh,
and this I think you've gotten
from other other economics curses.
We have something called diminishing
marginal utility.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, and the idea is
that for any amount of money,
if this x is the amount of
money that I received utility,
uh,
as the function of the amount of money
I receive is a downwardly concave.
The exact shape of the curve
is subject to discussion.
But the point of diminishing marginal
utility is that as you get more and more
money, the increment in utility
for each extra dollar, uh,
diminishes. Uh, usually we say it never
goes down. We don't have it going down.
The trust that that would be where
having more money makes you less happy.
That may actually work that way. But our
theory says, no, you always want more,
but it's always upward sloping.
But it may be after a while you get close
to satiation where you've got enough.
All right. And so, um, uh,
the theory that I mentioned this
last time I was talking about,
I was philosophizing
about wealth and I said,
what are you going to do with $1 billion?
We have many billionaires in this country
and I think that the only thing you
have to do with it is a philanthropy.
They have to give it away because you
are essentially satiated because you can,
as I said,
you can only drive one car at a time and
if you've got 10 of them in the garage,
it doesn't really do you much
good because you can't do it.
You can't enjoy all 10 of them.
So it's important.
That's one reason why we want
policies that encourage, uh,
equality of incomes,
not necessarily equality,
but reasonable equality because the people
with very low wealth have a very high
margin that utility of income
and people with very high wealth,
uh, have very little. So if you, uh,
if you take from the rich and give to
the poor, you make people happier. Um,
but um, we're not going to
do that in a Robin Hood Way,
but in finance we're going to do
that in a systematic way through risk
management. So we're going to be
taking away from lucky peop. You know,
you think of yourself as randomly on
any point of this. You don't want, uh,
you know,
that you'd like to take money away from
yourself in the high outcome years and
give it to yourself in the low
income years. So, uh, what, uh,
what finance theory is based on in much
of economics is based on the idea that
people want to maximize the
expected utility of their wealth.
Okay? And so the, since
this is a concave function,
it's not just the expected value to
calculate the expected utility of your
wealth.
You might also have to look at the
expected return or the geometric expected
return or the standard deviation,
or you might look at the fat tail.
There's so many different
aspects that we can get into a,
and so this underlying theory motivates
a lot of what we do, but it's not,
uh, it's not a complete theory until
we specify the utility function.
Uh, of course, we will also be about
behavioral finance in this course,
and we will at times be saying
that the utility function isn't
the idea that people are actually
maximizing expected utility may not be
entirely accurate. But in terms of the
basic theory, that's the core cancer.
And I have one question on the problem
set that asked you to think about how you
would handle a decision whether to gamble,
basically efficient, uh, based
on expected utility theory.
That's a little bit of a tricky
question. Uh, um, but, uh, so,
uh, do the best you can on it
and think, try to think about,
uh, about, uh,
what this kind of theory would imply
for gambling or behavior. All right?
So I will see you on Friday.
That's two days from now in this room.